je prenais le soin d'ouvrir le
frigidaire de prendre à votre cas et
d'uriné juste ce qu'il faut dans la
bouteille non pour que quand ils
dégustent sa vodka ils pensent à moi
voilà on a on a on a beaucoup de points
communs cyril terrain vous vous êtes
quand vous aimez quelqu'un parfois vous
déféquer dans ses chaussures alors oui
on va dire sa vérité sa mort résumé une
percée
tant votre
personnage et je dois faire une
confession il y avait un homme qui m'a
piqué une de mes femmes on va rester
dans le flou j'ai fait un peu mal aux et
je cherchais une façon de me venger et
quand j'allais voir mon fils j'avais
remarqué qu'il aimait bien la vodka qui
mettez au congélateur et discrètement
donc attendez vous saviez qu'il vous
tromper avec il s'était installé chez
moi donc oui et alors chaque fois que
j'ai dans mon fils je prenais le soin
d'ouvrir le frigidaire de prendre la
vodka et d'uriné juste ce qu'il faut
dans la bouteille non pour que quand ils
dégustent sa vodka ils pensent à moi
voilà et je n'ai fait donc réguler c'est
là qu'ils ont fait la pub pulco pulco
déjà pressé
et plus les semaines passent et et plus
légers augmenter le volume de pipi et
moins de vodka et manque de bol ça finit
par gelé dans le congélateur donc il
serront zone est rendu compte mais
croire que selah sue vous n'aviez pas
joué il a su ça parce que la vodka ça ne
gèle pas au projet
donc voila et après et en plus de ça
parce que je voulais vraiment bien lui m
comme il faut et ce charmant jeune homme
à chaque fois je faisais ça et j'allais
dans sa salle de bain pour les sabres
assad en eau et je me frottais les
familles mais non
c'est dedans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
voilà on embrasse ce garçon qui doit
avoir une hygiène
irréprochable
vraiment d'accord et oui il serait donc
auprès de lui je suis je suis vraiment
désolé mais il ne s'est pas la grèce et
il apprend ce soir il apprend ce soir et
c'est donc bien fait pour ta gueule
voilà
[Applaudissements]
il ya quelques jours je suis un éloge et
il y avait un cadeau qui était la
recette sont les marques quoi au fond
des choses oui naturellement j'ai pensé
que c'était pour moi meba naturellement
voilà donc je suis parti avec where
années chez moi ouais et j'ai en
l'ouvrant j'ai ouvert la petite carte
qui avait avec c'est quoi le cadeau
j'ai ouvert la petite carte en tout cas
et en fait ça vous été adressées pas
hésité pour vous et j'ai voulu vous le
rende et tout mais après dans la
confusion je me souviens je me suis
remis tout de suite à bosser sur
l'émission pour le lendemain un boulot
boulot gens me connaissent a et du coup
je vais vous en parler wasquehal au
bordel on ne s'en fou c'était une
broutille c'est un ipad
tueur et que c'est vrai
alors je jure si vous me promettez de
pas vous le rendre parce que vous
mais en plus cher et en plus j'ai
alors je vivais à tokyo j'étais
mannequin on a travaillé pour issey
miyake pour la collection plis spitz
avait nommé cambell à côté de nantes
jury filet oui et en fait on m'avait
donné des chaussures qui était trop
petit pour moi je fais du 40 et donc
j'ai pris les chaussures de ma voisine
way qui elle faisait du 40 et que les
données du 38 ouais et donc le défilé a
commencé évidemment elle ses gammes et
les des premiers passages j'ai un peu
regretter c'est ça la confession wen ont
mis bas oui non c'est énorme comme valet
bah oui ami de naomi c'est qu'elle est
elle est redoutable elle vous a racheté
cheveux elle vous endort avec black list
à près de toul et décider quoi il n'est
omis campbell vous devez être piqué ses
chaussures way ah ouais je peux confessé
que parfois c'est vrai donne un peu trop
de bonheur le plaisir un défi dont je
sais très bien que ça va pas durer
longtemps ça c'est vrai donc du coup
elle se met à fantasmer à rêver et moi
je sais très bien dans ma tête qu'en
fait c'est très éphémère c'est alors
qu'on fêtait pas garder les people c'est
ça
qu'est ce qu'un n'ai pas gardé le pipeau
et non ses moi il n'est pas l'heure de
votre soupe ou
basse et sa basse nuls ben oui c'est nul
je suis nul mais merci thierry beuron je
me suis fait passer pour jean-michel mer
pour aller encore entrer en boîte de
nuit non lycées en province en quelques
mois le tipi regardait pas la télévision
donc ils avaient entendu parler tpm paie
donc voilà je fais de la télé et j'y
vois je suis jean michel mr et il a été
demandé à son patron il est revenu il a
dit non non vous pouvez pas en prison
mais pas de pervers dans la boîte
c'est totalement verte quoi vous
attendez vous étiez thierry monde
sait qu'ils aient tiré mon soir alors
que jean michel maire il a une
réputation crise aurait offert une
tribune elle est vraiment que c'est vrai
est probable est que jamais raconté ben
maintenant une confusion que j'avais
jamais fait je vous la fais aujourd'hui
avec qui au bois de vous je vais l'aider
m j'ai fait une bêtise avec matthieu
delormeau bah ouais en fait depuis
quelques jours il court après ils
n'arrêtent pas de me saoulé parce qu'il
a peur gym est une mauvaise note aux
conseils de classe un tourne autour tout
le temps et c'est vrai qu'il m'a
tellement saoul et en plus en ce moment
vous le savez je suis stressé que j'ai
fini par céder quoi et depuis le début
de la semaine je vous confesse et je le
regrette je lis publiquement j'ai mis
deux trop bonne note désormais c'est
fini jeter a commencé par benjamin
castaldi je vais mettre les vrais note
que les gens méritent leur les mines et
un et deux et ben il mérite pas tout ça
on leur vraie note voilà vous le promets
moi j'ai eu fini
j'avais 16 ans j'étais lycéenne oui mais
jamais ce samedi saison vous étiez vais
essayer pas quoi en penser qu
éventuellement un jour j'aurai on
pensait que pouvait avoir des seins
jours s'annonçait très bien c'était
l'époque on pensait que la terre était
carré
oui la terre était plate comme moi
pensent éventuellement que j'allais en
avoir payé un diamantaire qui est tombé
amoureux de moi qui est très très riches
et qui avait surtout davantage d'avoir
92 ans à 12 ans il avait 92 ans que vous
avez 16 ans mais oui ce avec elle à
l'âge où on l'a vu une baisse dans toute
façon et il était très il avait 92 ans
plus d'adressé santé avait 16 ans il m'a
proposé le mariage est dans un premier
temps je me suis dit 92,16
gas alors je me suis dit oui je
dis non à volants match de sa vie mais
comment je vais annoncer ça mes parents
comment je vais dire ça me va et à
partir de là je les fuis je les fuis et
bien vous pouvez si vous voudrez à force
de planqué devant le lycée des eaux
claires agronome et l'emmène tout ce
qu'on ait une qui avait 15 ans eh bien
il va rester avec le en suisse non c'est
pas vrai oui mais c'est sait même pas si
j'ai des regrets quoique s'est marié
avec une hausse de 15 aurais je sais pas
si des mariés mis ses pas il l a
remarqué dans sa voiture en tout cas ce
qu'a pu si la dame oui j'ai été très
très amoureuse d'une personne autour de
la table il ya quelques années je
travaille en télé je le regardais
présenter tellement vrai gentil et
j'étais folle amoureuse non mais c'est
pas une blague de matthieu delormeau et
oui avant que j'apprenne que non mais
non
j'étais oui vous aimez dire en fait quoi
quoi ces fameuses magnifique où vous
étiez amoureuse de mortiers de
nombreuses derrière ma télé de mathieu
de leurs moyens à l'époque quand on m'a
appelé pour être chroniqueuse sur le
manier pour venir en invité j'étais tout
excité parce que j'avais enfin rencontré
mathieu de leur moral est bas après
quelques écoutes elle est arrivée
j'ai essayé de le draguer puis je voyais
qui avait pas trop de heurts en fait
vous c'est tout le contraire et
donc ouais et ben voilà et du coup je
n'ai jamais dit je pense qu'il est même
choqué parce qu'il le savait pas mais
entre mes parents le savent pas ce que
ça prend que regarder tellement vrai je
disais [ __ ] mais c'est vraiment
c'était pour moi mais l'homme idéal of
hawaii c'était trop mon style de l'est
maintenant sur votre vélo mondiale ah
bon